welcome back everybody this is our
continuing coverage of democracy 2020 on
special report let's take a look at some
of the other headlines that are out
there tonight
the united states is this story has
taken a little bit of a backseat over
the last couple of days but it certainly
is not
uh standing by at all 10 million mark
for covet 19 cases the current total is
almost 9.7 million the united states
death count has surpassed
235 000 globally
cases are nearing the 50 million mark
with almost
one and a quarter million fatalities the
u.s job market showed a burst of
strength in october with employers
adding 638 000 jobs the unemployment
rate
tumbling to 6.9 percent that is down a
full percentage point
from september job growth was
particularly strong in construction
retail
and a category that includes restaurants
and hotels it's great news we're going
to talk about it
with charles payne in a second stocks
were mixed today the dow lost 67
s p 500 fell one and the nasdaq finished
ahead
by four for the week all three exchanges
had their best runs since
april the dow surging almost seven
percentage points the s p 500 gained
seven in the third
the nasdaq jumped nine